a native of juice Pakistan with a green
card is accused of carrying out New
York's deadliest terror attack in years
eight people were killed and 11 others
were hurt police say that the suspects I
fool Oh sigh pop drove a rented pickup
truck for nearly a mile yesterday down a
back down a bike path along the West
Side Highway the truck flattened
cyclists and pedestrians in his way the
driver finally crashed into a school bus
not far from the new new one World Trade
Center police shots I - took him into
custody moments after the attack my law
enforcement source says a note was found
in the truck that made a reference to
Isis
Noor O'Donnell is in lower Manhattan
near the scene of the attack good
morning Nora hey good morning to you
that's right we're just about 50 yards
from where this attack came to an end
actually the car is still there that
truck and police say it took cyfle osai
path just minutes to plow through people
on this bike path that runs along the
Hudson River
investigators believe at this point that
he acted alone
they say there's no evidence of a wider
plot but the truck driver caused utter
chaos right here he bone the driver he
didn't look like he was bleeding or
anything per se he did have a noticeable
limp as he was getting out of his car he
did look like he was dragging his foot a
little bit and he was screaming in the
street suddenly then I heard the
gunshots then I just went down because I
was scared after the guns like five six
gunshots I didn't know which force the
gunshots coming from I just heard it
then I saw that guy he is down on the
ground and the cops just caught him and
at first I thought was fireworks so we
walked over to see what was going on and
then we get up there and we see two
bodies just on the floor we were just
shocked this is a tragedy the greatest
magnitude for many people for many
families here in New York City and
beyond today I want to command a
response for NYPD officer that was on
post near the location who stopped the
carnage moments after it began
yeah you heard the NYPD Commissioner
mentioned officer Ryan Nash who was one
of the first emergency responders on the
scene he's the one who shot the suspect
in the abdomen he was treated at
Bellevue for some ringing in his ears
five of the eight people who died in the
attack were friends from Argentina they
were actually in New York here
celebrating a 30-year high school
reunion
another victim was from Belgium but has
not been identified the 29 year old
suspect lived for some time in Tampa
Florida he also lived in Ohio and
investigators believe he most recently
lived in New Jersey sigh pop came to the
u.s. in 2010 from Uzbekistan President
Trump tweeted this morning that Saipa
entered through the diversity visa
lottery program which the president says
he wants to and and of course this
morning waking up to what has happened
but you see there's there's about three
blocks you know in one block radius here
from from where this all ended and I've
seen students already going back to
school this city trying to return to
normal even as though this block is
still completely blocked up by law
enforcement as they continue their
investigation I'll send it back to you
bianna in studio 57 nor that is my
neighborhood and I can vouch for the
resilience of those that live in the
neighborhood in and in New York as a
whole thank you